[Applause]
also I wanted to mention tonight that if
you want to get in our flip a district
campaign now is the time yeah that
wasn't needed that was some [ __ ]
right there we could never get that five
seconds back last week we introduced our
tweet 16 bracket and by popular demand
the first two public embarrassments we'd
like to nominate for unseating are
Michael Grimm New York's 11th district
he's a guy who thrusts himself into the
running this year by threatening to
throw a reporter off the balcony of the
Capitol he seems to be all of Staten
Island distilled in one man and there is
a lot of enthusiasm out there for making
him to go away he's our first the other
guy you're introducing this week I was
doing stand-up in Corpus Christi a
couple of months ago right after we
introduced Philippa district and
everybody down there was talking about
Blake Farenthold
and that's that's just that's his
purposeful head job this is like as good
easy can look when he tries he is their
congressman and you can't blame me but
I'm pulling for this guy through it I
mean he is the poster boy for why we are
doing this he won in 2010 by 799 votes
and then they redistricted it
they gerrymandered it and in 2012 he won
going away by 18 points folks we need a
realistic chance
so if pajama boy is going to be our guy
you folks down there in Corpus Christi
district got to get his lead down into
single digits I am NOT a miracle worker
let's not forget Obama's phrase in 2008
was yes we can
okay there's 14 slots left send us your
pics by social media use hashtag Flippa
district